it's easy to break something it doesn't
take much time at all
putting it back together takes more time
we should not expect a change overnight
or in the short run
[Music]
unfortunately across the country
generally there is this hopelessness
that there's really nothing that can be
done fortunately that's not the case
there are actually a number of
evidence-based strategies that can lower
homicide rates and that can improve
homicide clearance rates
there's no one strategy but taken
together there's a toolbox out there
that can be used to reduce homicide
it is both an investment in law
enforcement and policing
and also the investments in violence
corruption
we need police at the table
in the middle of a unprecedented spike
in homicides this is the wrong time to
be decreasing police budgets
the priority are the murders the police
are not prioritizing
the woundings the way they should
we have to view non-fatal shootings as
more or less failed homicides
when a non-fatal shooting occurs it will
lead to a response from the other party
one non-fatal shooting can contribute to
somebody getting murdered three or four
or five steps down that sort of
ping-pong sequence
it really impedes the development of
police community trust it impedes
perceptions of police legitimacy
that feeds into these cycles where
people are unwilling to cooperate with
the police
catching more non-fatal shooters would
contribute to a reduction in violent
crime a number of ways it would mean
that
there's people not going to commit other
shooting offenses
in denver they developed a team of
detectives who are solely dedicated to
the investigation of non-fatal shootings
i think in their first several months
they went from a clearance rate of 39 on
shootings to 65
i don't think police departments and the
cities that run them can afford to
ignore the calls for reform they do that
at their own peril
the effects of viral video of police
officers drag racing squad cars or
really negative community interactions
actually makes it much harder for police
to help solve those homicides
if they was to get out
in the community
and not like we're in vietnam we would
see a huge difference in crime
one of the biggest problems with police
is
they don't
partner up with community
organizations
want to just push back on this notion
that whatever we do related to homicide
rates begins and ends with the police it
doesn't the police are necessary but not
sufficient
we've got to be able to have smart
approaches that really have our police
officers respond to the places where we
really need them but then also have
resources that go where you don't need a
police officer being a different type of
response
you don't know that people don't care
about going to jail
you know you can't just lock the shoot
up and think the problems go away that
don't happen
that's what the d.a and the police want
to think but they know that's that's not
the
case there's kind of three things that
can happen here buddy
you can continue in the game that you're
in
and find yourself a victim of gun
violence
you can continue the game that you're in
and find yourself
arrested and incarcerated or we can help
you find a way out of this
i had a gun charge that's what i went to
jail for 98.
when i came home though
in 2000
i told the lions i needed help
i wasn't even there right
i ended up going back to the streets and
that's again
the process i'm on that that's how long
it took me to come around the longer you
be in the streets the longer you're
going to take to get out because you get
caught up i haven't seen nobody could
just turn it off like that and just walk
away
that's why our conflict resolution life
skills classes are so important
to be able to show them that they have
more value than the gun
how do morals integrity and principles
look
because you're dealing with individuals
that have never been taught it becomes
our obligation to begin to teach this
one thing about being in that street
world
if you ain't never been in it
it's kind of real complicated to get in
and grasp it and try to pull somebody
out of it
when you work with these kids man and
then they go get killed
then you cry for a sec you know you
gotta
nothing you can do though
everybody's not gonna change that's the
whole process you're going to watch some
man going out to go to jail so i'm going
to die
but some of them gonna get it
and move past it
one sees a virtuous circle as the very
way out of
the vicious circle
we've gotten ourselves into especially
as of last year
the virtuous circle would have to
involve a rather sizable reduction in
homicide which would reduce the caseload
confronting the police
enabling them to solve more homicides
thereby increasing confidence in the
police by the community
all of that of course
depends on
whether there will be another viral
incident of police use of force
especially force used against a minority
member of our communities that enrages
people
where that to happen we're back to
square one
i hesitate to be all doom and gloom
because it's easy to sit here and say oh
it's the worst it's ever been there's
there's reason to be hopeful that maybe
five ten years from now we'll look back
at what was a two or three year spike
that was really bad but then maybe that
we got back on track
we are not short for resources
what we don't have is the type of
coordination that we need the different
organizations us coming together
could definitely curb the violence but i
believe that
the one thing that we all need to do is
give our kids time and attention
and that's the number one way how we
teach them and that's the number one way
how we can end this